foreign  [Music]  I sort of felt that I just wanted to  tell like a night in the life of Batman  you know but then when we hit on the  idea of of the blackout that that was  the one that was like oh okay that's the  that's the hook it all came out of that  simple idea that that he's got to get  from one side of Gotham to the other in  Total Blackout with no support and the  entirety of Gotham is kind of trying to  sort of get on top of him disable him  take him out take out EMP at a new  villain he's a very volatile character  he feeds on energy you know so that can  be electricity it can be emotional  energy and Batman having to to get this  guy from one side to the other you know  during this kind of crazy night is um is  a challenge I've spent the last year  already on this story and I'm putting  everything I've got into it and yeah I  can't wait for everyone to see it  [Music]  foreign